we're going to talk about the media
specifically one increasingly
influential member of it Alex Jones the
Walter Cronkite of shrinking batshit
gorilla clowns I know you might be
thinking there is nothing more I need to
know about Alex Jones because you've
probably seen crazy clips like this what
do you think tap water is it's a gay
bomb baby and I'm not saying people
didn't naturally have homosexual
feelings I'm not even getting into it
you think gay people I don't like
putting chemicals in the water they turn
the friggin frogs gay do you understand
that Wow if he's that upset about a
government conspiracy that is not
happening just imagine how upset he's
gonna be when he finds out about one
that actually is like the fact that the
government is turning raccoons bilingual
oh that's right they're all fluent in
French now and they will be working that
into conversation and that famous clip
is by no means an outlier Jones is a
charismatic performer who gets charged
up on a regular basis so there are
plenty of lesser-known outbursts like
this my spirit gets close to that evil
and I feel it and my whole spirit just
goes out
they call that crazy that's not crazy
that's my will my human spirits saying
crush those that would hurt the innocent
go after the enemy build a civilization
be honorable crush the snakes under your
feet well at least now we know what
Friday Night Lights would have looked
like if they'd given coach Taylor a
nasty PCP habit go after the enemy
ideally ideally the first thing you
should know about the Alex Jones Show is
nothing but unfortunately it is an
important part of a lot of people's
media diets an estimated 6 million
people listen to his radio show or watch
it online every week and we know at
least one Jones fan seems to be current
Russian ambassador to the United States
Donald Trump he he supposedly calls
Jones after the election has tweeted
content from Infowars and one of its
editors and just a year and a half ago
even appeared on his show I just want to
finish by saying your reputations
amazing I will not let you down
you will be very very impressed they
hope and I think we'll be speaking a lot
the only thing that could have made that
moment any grow says if Nigel Faraj Bill
Cosby and Phil Spector were all on the
same corner so look it is no wonder that
Jones has been getting a lot of coverage
recently we even mentioned him on our
first show of the season back in
February and in his response to it he
seemed a little annoyed with me your
ratings are in the toilet you're a joke
they brought you back revamped out of
the gates to attack yours truly have you
lectured us the Donald Trump could never
win over and over again there's you know
you're the intellectual everybody knows
the British accents intellectual fast
and now you make fun of me out of
context and and and although look at
this loon hey boy people want legitimacy
they want real they want to hear
somebody that could speak to them and
touch him inside okay
don't call me boy and to my British
accents does not sound intellectual
believe me I sound like a chimney sweep
passing through a wood chipper but but I
will give him this Jones is right that
too often people don't present him in
his full context so tonight we are going
to do that unless first set aside the
key context the Alex Jones has
repeatedly used his show to fuel
speculation that the Sandy Hook massacre
was staged by the government which has
been deeply hurtful for the parents of
those children over the years that is
disgusting and it should be
disqualifying in terms of ever taking
him seriously
sadly doing things that disqualify
you from being taken seriously doesn't
really seem to be much of a thing
anymore but but there is a piece of
context you may be less aware of and
that concerns the nature of Jones's show
itself it is four hours long and if you
tuned it to the whole thing you'll most
shocking discovery might be how
frequently and shamelessly he pitches
products that he sells in fact remember
that clip from him earlier yelling about
snakes let's just go back to that and
play it out a bit be honorable crush the
snakes under your feet get behind me
Satan now before I go any further before
I go any further we got to fund this
operation we got the very best
nutraceuticals out there I don't know if
I can run this for other week or so we
want to run through the end of the month
that's like 11 days cuz I don't want to
sell out for mortgage there next to the
good halogen 20% off in fours live.com
in fours live.com in fours live.com whoa
that is a hard turn to have to make the
saint watch being deep state god bless
are gonna murder you and your entire
family open your eyes people they are
coming for you they're coming for all of
us hmm
but first McGillicuddy's oatmeal the
perfect way to start your day
and look that quick is not an anomaly in
one week of recent broadcast on his site
we found he spent nearly a quarter of
the time either talking about or playing
ads for his products or pointing you to
the info war store and if you have never
gone shopping on Infowars you are in for
whatever the exact opposite of a
treatise because there's the kind of
survival gear that you would expect
alongside more surprising items like
organic shampoo body wash and deodorant
as well as products like combat one
tactical bath wipes a $10 pack of moist
towelettes that can be used anywhere
needed including the perineal area which
if you're wondering is this region right
here that's right Alex Jones is trying
to sell you sloppy wet rags for your
taint and and when you are done wiping
down the area between your genitals and
anus with a glorified wet nap why not
pick up a Bill Clinton rape whistle
which according to Infowars
should be used to let bill know you're
in the crowd and that you know the truth
that truth by the way you just spent six
dollars on a whistle oh that's right we
bought this and by the way our order
came with a free nine eleven was an
inside job bumper sticker that we most
assuredly did not ask for and radio host
doing ads is not inherently unusual but
since 2013 Jones has increasingly
focused on promoting his own products
which he sells on his site under his
Infowars life brand particularly
vitamins and nutraceuticals
at which I believe are the result of the
word nutrition the word
pharmaceutical from behind I'm pretty
sure that's what it is but this this is
a big part of Jones's business
two-thirds of his funding reportedly
comes from selling his products and
there are a lot of them and the reason I
know that is we bought a whole bunch now
down for you there is a super male
vitality super female vitality
wake up America patriot blends coffee
lung cleanse brain force plus something
called DNA force that costs a hundred
and twenty dollars a bottle and child
ease a herbal blend at which according
to Infowars is designed to soothe the
mind and bodies of children which is a
profoundly creepy phrase and then there
is caveman true paleo formula with bone
broth a chocolate flavored drink mix
made from bee pollen stevia and the dust
of chicken skeletons now according to
Infowars it is one of the most popular
new health trend in the world today and
by the look on junkies face it tastes
exactly as good as it sounds
portal at it on a couple ice cubes and
folks it tastes when it's creamy and
thick I think better than Ovaltine and
it is got all the bone broth and so much
more this is why the ancients they
believe we had such better bones or so
much healthier you look it up this you
could freeze this and this is way better
than like Bluebell chocolate ice cream
the alex jones did not enjoy drinking
that glass of caveman because I have got
a glass of plate man right here and I
can confirm to you that it takes
it takes exactly how you imagine a drink
would taste this made from chocolate and
domesticated birth corpses it comes at
you in waves and that is not the only
time that Jones has used himself as a
guinea pig to sell his own products and
a warning now to our younger viewers the
following footage of a man graphically
too comfortable with his own body may be
disturbing just ten months before we
taped this decided to do this cuz have
it us in a while we took photos a year
ago and then I gave about six months ago
and the weight loss is dramatic already
from what happened before okay so you're
ready and you're wearing a belt the only
thing I can discern happen between those
two photos is that you walk shirtless in
the Sun for two hours to a belt store
you could clip those two photos around
and the effect would be exactly the same
also look to be fair to Jobs he does
have a medical expert who consults on
many of his supplements dr. Edward Group
the third who looks like the lead in a
direct-to-dvd kato kaelin biopic but
he's actually even less impressive than
that here he is in an info wars ad
explaining the importance of one of the
products if you're suffering from
abdominal pain allergies even like
headaches anemia weakened immune system
gut problems depression hair loss excess
gas muscle pain nervousness I mean all
these things if you look at some of
these conditions and then us opening up
our borders and all the other countries
opening up our their borders you're just
dealing with a mass amount of parasites
or harmful organisms you can type in
refugees spreading disease I mean the
CDC is going crazy right now actually
I'm pretty sure that if you talk
refugees spreading disease into Google
and press ENTER it just takes you right
to the Wikipedia page for xenophobia
which at the end of the day is a real
time-saver for you but but despite the
fact that dr. group looks like what
would happen if Tom Petty was machine
washed instead of dried alleys
slash biking in fact he has been pretty
defensive about doctor groups
credentials there doesn't matter you've
got degrees from MIT and everywhere else
and a bunch of other degrees the media
makes fun of you and says that you're an
idiot
that's true they say we cannot sell
coffee it's a fraud that's right that's
right I've been a research scientist for
a long time I do have I am MIT alumni
and I can tell you that I do research
all the time okay stop let's break down
that bunch of degrees Jones mentioned
group does have a Doctor of Chiropractic
degree from Texas Chiropractic College
but well he listen lists all these other
schools on LinkedIn we checked and he
didn't graduate from any of them in fact
we asked him and he admits he does not
have an undergraduate degree and as for
whether he's an MIT alumni he only
completed a non degree certificate
program there in fact just to be sure we
contacted MIT and according to them it
is not accurate to say he has a degree
from MIT and calling him an alumni would
be inaccurate and misleading
this man does not look like an MIT
alumnus he looks like a fifth year
senior at the University of falling off
a surfboard so so just to clarify Alex
that is what we are making fun of when
we make fun of dr. group well that and
the fact that he looks like what would
happen if Iggy Pop got the Rachel look
Jones can inflate dr. groups credentials
all he wants he says a lot of crazy
on his show but it is noticeable that
when it comes to selling his supplements
he can sometimes show a caution that is
pretty out of character just watch him
bend over backwards to repeatedly
qualify what he says seconds after he
said it maybe you've had back pain
before maybe you've had nerves that were
cut off this creates tingling this has
illogical Heather feeling come back I'm
not gonna make claims his research true
organically based bio pqq it's not
technically organic the other stuff
synthetic you're pretty mad lab mate
this is made from organic sources but
the bacterias GMO I'll just tell you up
front but it's not like the super
high-tech stuff it's a bacteria that's
just been bred to be able to then
secrete and produce this just like beer
is bacterial thought a good bacteria
obviously but this one that's how the
Japanese do it but it's bioidentical the
stuff is only found in comics and in
trace amounts and blueberries
right
okay so let's break that down it repairs
nerves but maybe doesn't it's organic
but not really
it contains GMOs which is bad except for
when he's selling you something and you
can only find it ingredients in comets
oh and blueberries and it's the drop-off
after that last one that is really
incredible you can only find this stuff
in dinosaur bones and in trace amounts
in Ritz bits and look jones's product
don't come cheap for instance he sells
this one fluid ounce bottle of vitamin
d3 for 2995
but ConsumerLab calm a supplement
watchdog points out that you can buy the
same amount of d3 from other sources for
less than four dollars but Jung's will
often give you a hard sell sometimes
he'll tell you if his products are
different than the ones that you can
find in stores and sometimes he'll go
even bigger it is absolutely in the
crystalline form the strongest you
absorb it so folks don't go out of the
store and get iodine from say one of the
big change it'll kill you Wow I honestly
did not know that you can employ your
competition kills people four out of
five dentists prefer Trident gum and the
fifth dentist is dead because he put a
piece of Wrigley's in his mouth and
that's basically suicide and Tahir Jones
telling him don't sell it his products
are marked up just enough to keep his
business going as he explained in his
recent appearance on rationalizing low
ratings with megyn kelly and it cost
forty five fifty million dollars a year
Romo how much money's being made well
the money that's made is pretty much put
back in the face okay so that is
remarkable for two reasons first forty
five to fifty million dollars is a lot
of money and second Jones would have you
believe that every penny they earn is
being plowed back into a show that looks
like it was filmed on the set of a
low-budget porn parody of itself
in fact as he frequently tells his
audience he needs them to buy more to
keep his truth-telling crusade solvent
and growing we need to fund ourselves
and we fund ourselves by you buying the
products we're at a shortfall now
because of the massive sustained
economic attacks were under but the
listeners in just two weeks of almost
narrowed that gap I could have to sell
my house to keep this place running
three four months I could have sponsors
every segment I don't do it I plug
enough to fund things
fund us give me the energy and I will
attack the enemy it's like an NPR pledge
drive for people who hate NPR because to
listen to junks Infowars is perpetually
on the edge of disaster
he even has a link on the info war store
where you can just give him money to
help fund the fight against tyranny and
contributors have left comments like $25
may not be much but I know every little
bit helps
but junk seems to be doing a bit more
than just keep his head above water
ex-employees described a thriving
business with one saying he can sell 500
supplements in an hour
it's like QVC for conspiracy and in one
of those Clips we showed earlier we
noticed he's wearing what looks like a
Rolex watch worth around $8,000 which
cool and as we looked around we notice
he also seems to have another two
different Rolexes and you know cooler
and here's the thing that is honestly
fine he can have fancy watches there is
nothing wrong with him getting paid
I get paid to make this show but it does
fight with his message that he needs you
to buy products to help keep his show
going and even Alex Jones seems to be a
little self-conscious about that
disconnect but don't worry he's
reconciled it in a truly amazing way I
wear a blue sports coat and a Rolex
because it's a symbol of middle class
and humanity having prosperity and
promoting human prosperity from a
perspective of empowering humanity and
stealing the image of a man in a sports
jacket with a Rolex that is the satanic
image so I dress
as a Satanist so that I could enter
their world and show you that none of it
means anything Oh how stupid do
you think your audience is okay you
bought a Rolex so you could dress up
like a Satanist what are the other two
for and it's intently tormenting the
parents of Sandy Hook should comfortably
get you into the satanic Club I believe
that's the easy pass to whatever the
hell's version of the champagne room is
and look at the start of this piece I
promised Alex jung's that I would put
his statements in context because he is
right that if you play small clips in
isolation he looks like a loon but if
you play them in context he looks like a
skilled salesman spending hours a day
frightening you about problems like
refugees spreading disease and then
selling you an answer remember that gay
frog clip at the start he did a
follow-up show explaining how chemicals
were being placed in the water to
feminize society and reduce the
population and then immediately segue to
this we shall five different brands of
the very best water water filtration
systems out there they're amazing they
cut out 99.99% of the glyphosate the
herbicides the pesticides the fluoride I
mean to an untrained eye it sure seems
like he was using the idea of a gay frog
to sell his products which incidentally
is the same mistake the WB network mate
I'm not saying I am NOT saying the only
reason Jones is talking about the
globalist systematically feminizing us
is to sell overpriced nutraceuticals so
we can buy luxury watches but if I were
saying that it certainly wouldn't be the
stupidest conspiracy theory that you've
heard so far tonight
so if Alex Jones wants his words in
context this is it the fact that he
happens to sell so many solutions should
really Rican how you think about what he
is claiming our problems think about it
like this how would you feel if at the
end of this segment that may well have
made you feeling a little dirty I tried
to sell you something to wipe that gross
feeling away would you question my
motives well I certainly hope not
because that's what we are doing right
probably because I'm proud to say that
we be working with a leading medical
expert and I would like you to meet him
right now please please welcome
happy to have you and we are here the
doctor and I to offer you the John
Oliver moisture armor two tactical
assault wipe the first tactical wipe for
use exclusively on the perineum that's
right
for goodness sake don't use this
anywhere else you're gonna wanna just
focus right on this area right okay
now doctor doctor how is this going to
make people feel better about what
they've seen tonight well my studies
show that when you vigorously arrive
this paint white it causes a sensation
that distracts the brain from whatever
had previously been thinking about okay
and again you've got degrees from MIT
and everywhere else and a bunch of other
degrees the media makes fun of you and
says you're an idiot they do it just for
the record you did go to MIT right well
I've definitely physically been there
now you can actually buy one of these
wipes at info wipes calm for 1 million
dollars this is real they are actually
available for a million dollars apiece
and don't even think about buying a
similar wipe in a store because those
wipes will kill you also
these lights have the power to
heterosexual eyes frogs so that's very
nice to have cuz that's been a real
problem what with all the refugees right
look this tactical tank wipe has
demonstrated incredible results
absolutely it sure has look at this
photo of me and now look at this photo
of me 45 minutes later after buying the
tank like you
you're much better behind so much red so
if you want to spend a million dollars
on a tank wipe go to info whites comm
and if you are thinking well no one's
going to do that all I will say is
people pay Alex Jones $45 for a jar of
chocolate flavored chicken juice so
anything is possible
[Applause]